la tap emilie est in ou sa famille
d'accueil ou six de la même communauté
sur la côte nord une famille accrédité
par le centre de protection de la
jeunesse c'est suite à une annonce il
avait été fait à la radio comme de quoi
qui qui marquait des familles d'accueil
hâter sa maîtrise et qui avait comme
jean le crise qu'il fallait qu'il place
des jeunes en réserve un certain
extérieur bprd y perdaient leur langue
perdaient leur culture veut veut pas
leur étaient des res mai puis c'est une
manière à nous de donner un coup de main
on a beaucoup d'amour à donner on avait
en avait de la place dans la mer mais il
ya un hic pour s'occuper d'emilie ils
reçoivent moins d'argent que les autres
familles d'accueil québécoise deux fois
moins 20 36 + 5 dollars le 6 dollars par
jour au total 31 dollars et 36 par jour
une famille d'accueil québécoise reçoit
plus du double au minimum 71 dollars par
jour selon les barèmes de la fédération
des familles d'accueil
et si la famille d'accueil permettez-moi
blanche québécoise une ville reçoit un
enfant autochtone de la contenant d'une
des réserves de lakota combien cette
femme il pas récemment un jeune qui est
placée directement par le centre
jeunesse ou encore que ce soit un jeu
qui provient d'une réserve autochtone ça
changera pas son montant
donc c'est vraiment elle va vous
recevoir le même montant si c'est un
jeune d'une communauté ou si c'est d'un
jeune qui vient d'une ville le voisin
autrement dit si emilie était placé au
village voisin
sa famille d'accueil serait mieux payés
qu'ici sur la réserve des familles
d'accueil ils nous ont découvert cela
dernièrement chez absolument une
injustice moi je trouve qu'un que c'est
on a suivi les mêmes critères
d'admission pour être pour être famille
d'accueil on en penser les modèles de la
marque
si sam a enfin c'est le même a faim